hi and welcome to this talk
this chalk it's a little bit difficult
to given maybe not for you but for me
because this is a very very dynamic
field which is evolving rapidly so one
thing I want to note is I am NOT a
physicist I don't have a PhD in physics
but I am a data scientist I am machine
learning expert so I think I can relate
to you in the order of things I want to
know before arriving at a new field so I
hope this talk shows that and we can
increase out now our knowledge of this
very exciting field ok let's start with
the motivation you know instead a need
for a new kind of computing the answer
is clearly yet yes you you experiment
this every time in your current work
there's no enough cheap used to train
models we were always looking for ways
to get more more power more computing
power and as you know we have them the
Moore's Law running from for around 30
years they be the power of the computers
is increasing more or less linearly but
it's getting more and more difficult to
get power from the current architectures
what's the reason ok we are more or less
in the order of 20 items per transistors
and you know there is a limit one
transistor per one atom per transistor
will be the last limit which is to be
reached like in I don't know 30 40 years
and the other problem is it's really
expensive to build
transistors of one two three items
because the quantum mechanics of that
sort of mechanism starts to to bother
and we have an effect called the
tunneling effect by which the the
electrons go and pass by the device when
they are worn to items so this the
quantum effects start to to bother us
just that this stage in the
technological advance we have some like
efforts from cerebral building very very
large dyes for the new processors twenty
twenty centimeters but you know we are
in a couple of years we will be going
back to the ENIAC with rooms full of
computers a computer occup in one room
so this is not a clever option so
classical computing is based on
transistors the limit is one transistor
a one atom for transistors so we have
channel effects so we are now just
working with quantum effects let's use
it for profit this story more or less
begins in 1981 what happened that there
in MIT Massachusetts in 1981 there was a
conference of the physics of computation
so there was if you will see that the
whole picture this is like a most nerdy
picture you see they're all kind of
geniuses gathered in MIT and try to find
new ways of computing using physics for
example imitating nature and
in many ways and for example the
Brownian movement of particles and there
was this genius Richard Feynman which
proposed to use the quantum effects
quantum computers to to emulate so
saying that ok nature is quantum period
so if we want to do the ultimate
computing device you should emulate
nature and use quantum computers so we
should be able to solve problems
impossible for classical computers ok
before starting with the specifics I
will go with three slides explaining why
why quantum is so weird design it's not
clear is if it was fireman Bohr or other
say if you think you understand quantum
mechanics you don't understand the
mechanics because it's really such a
three concepts for our minds to
understand what happened what happened
in the very visual scales in nature and
I'll try to describe it this with three
main phenomena the first phenomenon
occurring at the quantum scale which is
less than nanometers is the
superposition and it's like a cliche but
it's normally explained by the
Schrodinger's cat which is you have a
black box in these cases like a crystal
you know that just plain with a cat in
and there is a radioactive element and
this this there is a Geiger counter
if radioactivity is detected so a bottle
of poison is opened and the cat is dead
but you don't see anything from there
from the exterior side so
what happens is that if you if you see
the problem from a quantum perspective
and the radioactive radioactive matter
has a 0.5 probability of emitting
radioactivity
the cat is at the same time half there
and half alive you know this is the way
we see these things from the quantum
perspective the other strange phenomenon
is the the measurement of phenomenon it
consists in that when you measure a
quantum particle of our system
you lose information in the K in some
sense in the case of the box with a cat
when we open the box we don't see any
probabilities anymore we see okay it's
alive or it said that occurs with all
the quantum elements in nature and the
the other is strange but mathematically
valid phenomena is the entanglement with
entanglement when you have two you two
particles in the quantum scale and you
can separate all the way from one point
of the universe to to other and if they
are the entangled and you measure them
the those measurements will be totally
coherence so it's like a spooky action
as at a distance and even Einstein had
many problems to grasp and understand
and even accept the concept so we have
to we need to having a clear that all
the this I am explaining right now it
took 25 years to the best minds of the
earth to grasp understand and accept so
it is a it's a little bit difficult
classic
is easy quantum is a little difficult
okay let's go from quantum mechanics -
Quentin information how can we store and
manipulate information in the quantum
realm
well the minimal unit of information in
the quantum realm is a qubit normally
qubits in like abstract notion but it
can be seen like a quantum mechanical
systems system which has three main
properties it has two quantum two main
Quentin levels stores quantum
information and you can entangle qubits
and they have a superposition as I
explained before so this is a little
picture explaining more or less a view
of how a classical bit it's seen and a
cubit the cubed ice you see is really a
complex figure and in in mathematical
includes complex numbers so it's complex
in many ways ok the only three slides
with mathematics on it I promise
ok how can we represent qubits to
understand them the first one is a
vector with two coefficient alpha and
beta and alpha and beta represent the
probabilities of being in one of the
normal classical States you know they
are square and we take the modulus
another way of representing them is as
use you probably see so in linear
algebra using vectors basis vectors
which are orthonormal and they can
represent all the vector space so
we have this second representation which
is a linear combination and this is a
thing I've learned just not so in the
time that we tend to use a strange word
for common phenomena for example
superposition is a linear combination
and if you if I say you okay it's a
linear combination of states if you went
to linear algebra cars you understand
everything but we tend to use a strange
word like superposition and there are
many others to represent a very
well-known concept so taking account
when we speak about superposition is a
linear combination of states in we are
going here to a third way of
representing these types of a qubit we
start with the linear combination of
factors then we combine that with the
fact that alpha and beta and are complex
numbers and we have another limitation
this limitation is by nature because you
know the sum of probabilities of had
probability distribution is only s is
just 1 so we have the this limit that
the sum of the probabilities is 1 and
this moves us into thinking okay this is
really like a sphere in the complex
field so we mapped everything into the
complex field and with some pages of
math we have this representation so now
we are representing a qubit inside a
sphere of radius 1 and the parameters
are angles you know
so with this a pair of angles you can
represent the information this will be
very useful in the future trust me I
won't bother you with
much more mathematics then there is a
third way of representing using the
bracket notation the only thing I will
mention is that you represent the states
of of a cubit user brackets and brackets
is another weird name to vectors and
they have this new representation and in
other as we are in the complex space in
order to calculate the probability of
estate collapsing when you measure
another one is given by the dot product
of the vectors
okay I said enough mat just one more
let's let's review a little bit okay
this is fair is called the blogosphere
this is a this comes from very early
mathematics and some quantum mechanics
related to the spin of the electron
so this states in the blogosphere are
angles the poles are the binary bits as
we know them they could cover the whole
surface of the sphere the classical bits
under north and south and the perfect
entanglement is and given at the equator
if we are representing it around the
equator they are perfectly entangled and
so they bother me
they're in perfect circle position so
the both states have the same
probability okay now we have the unit
for representing information in the
quantum beyond what's the advantage of
it
okay the advantage is that with normal
beats you have the product into an M is
exact as possible States you know the
number of beats multiplied by 2 but the
qubits can you have a measure of all the
possible states at the same time as you
know when you you reach the the 300
number of qubits you get to animal like
the number of stars in the universe you
know so imagine we are now at 53 qubits
in the most powerful computer we are not
so far for 300 and see how many
probabilities you can contemplate in one
operation that's the main point in this
field is advancing in a really quick way
we start from 1981 but from 1998 and
successful successful computer we had
many successful iterations in the
[Music]
interval from 2005 and 16 and as you as
you see the the great interest there is
now in quantum computers is doing like
it increases at an explanation right
Righetti around said the they have a
hundred and twenty I quit machine in
preparation and with an announcement I I
will comment right now it will explode
I think just it will be crazy
okay qubits are not one type of
mechanism like transistors we have many
implementations of codes for example
spin qubit which measure the spin of an
electron ion traps supper conducting
circuits which measure two different
and photonic circuits which uses photons
are the quantum elements okay this is
enough with mathematics and physics and
now we'll be going to what really
interested it's just us and motivates us
which is programming and using the
computers any questions comments
no you're right that at the moment the
quantum computers are like coprocessors
so you have to you need a mechanism to
transfer from the cpu to the quantum
device and then from from the quantum
device to the computer like it was with
CPU or the other start you know that the
memories were totally isolated and you
you wanted you needed to put all your
your arrays in the CPU memory and that
get it back this is quantum computers
and are in this state you you have to
upload and download the results so to
say ok let's continue sir
how can we program on how do we build
quantum circuits and programs ok the the
qubits has a very clear path in in the
life of a program first you initialize
to this lowest energy state which is 0
you manipulate it with gates it's really
like electronics basic electronics but
in another sense and then you measure
and once you measure all is said you
have to start again you know the good
things the good thing is that you can
repeat the experiments many times even
thousands of times so this is the power
of this kind of computing you can
explore many status and then repeat it
but it is quick how do we represent the
quantum circuits okay we have
standardized symbols like a qubit is a
line then the classical which is Cho
lion's gate is a square
a measurement is like a measurement
device and the time runs from left to
right so it's really easy to understand
here for example we are we have five
cubits we are not using three or three
of them here here we are applying a gate
another type of gate this is another
type that we will see after that and
then we measure this is the whole
lifecycle I let's take a look at the
different types of gates the one of the
most important gates if they had a
Margate it basically it takes a normal
classical bit and it get the the qubit
into a perfect separate position state
and vice versa
so in order to get into the quantum
realm you have to apply these this gate
then we have the poly X Y and C gates
which they just flip around this the
state of the qubit as you can see in the
graphic it's very clear I think then we
have a gate called C not gate it's in
this case we have a control qubit and if
it's set to zero it doesn't change the
controlled Q it but if it's at one it
changed 180 degrees the last one we need
is the toefl gate which is it needs a Y
signal here both of these which set 1 in
order to invert the the previous input
so as you see it doesn't change anything
until we have double one here and it
flips the distal this state
right we are approaching the the cool
side so how can we right now get our
hands into quantum computing with bytes
so I will review five services we now
have more or less available there are
three that you can just go to that you
can go and subscribe the other three are
a little more difficult but fortunately
we have two of them that we can use
right now the first one I had to mention
this Monday Amazon announced Amazon
bracket so I built AWS has a proper
quantum environment to offer and this is
huge because I I can predict that this
will make the field splode you know and
we have an environment to explore test
and run different quantum computing
technologies and we have three different
providers and the interesting thing is
that the way uses adiabatic computing
imq use an ion use uses ion traps and
Righetti another technology so we have
three different kinds of implementations
or qubits to play with I subscribed to
the early adapter but I wasn't accepted
so this is all like that I can show you
yesterday I think there was a workshop
maybe it's online I don't know you can
review it in the AWS reinvent conference
which is taking place in the in Las
Vegas
then we have the to more realistic
options IBM quantum experience this this
is an environment in which you can run
experiments they have like six computers
open to you and at the moment it was all
free for me I have like 15 credits but
but they don't reduce so like at the
moment I able to mind back Bitcoin I
don't know but didn't have any really
big problems to tackle and then we have
the Righetti quantum computing services
this is a very good company because it's
independent from the big guys but they
have a very good approach and they are
doing very very good things and you can
access their computers right now
then from the parts of Google we have
the D Y bleep in which you can use your
da adiabatic quantum computers the
problem with those computers is that
it's a different kind of problems you
want to solve and it's not nearly as
complete as we as the Righetti and IBM's
so this is for more optimization
problems type of problems
I'll go first with IBM already if I will
start right now and then we have
Microsoft with Asia quantum they are
promising also three providers I don't
have access to I asked but not accepted
so I can tell you much more than that
but the good thing is every one of them
they are using Python tools they are
using ship in the lab you have a
complete Python toolkit running in the
background so for the Python programmer
quantum computer is like a very good
landscape right now okay just an
introduction to the different frameworks
iBM has kisk it really has a forest ATK
they are the names of their quantum
computing Python libraries but they work
almost the same for the basic problems
and they are very easy to understand and
we have like a rosetta stone which I
will show you a little later for the way
we have ocean SDK and for Microsoft as
they tend to do they have their own
language cue sharp but it has like
Python bindings so you can also program
a sure quantum through issue in quantum
through Python in a special mention to
Xanadu which is a very interesting firm
which has penny line in strawberry
fields which are one is a quantum
computing library and the other is a
symbol simulator and quantum prominent
studio which is a web page in which
you'll be able to build share and even
get the representation of your secret
and in many many different approaches so
maybe you can tinker around in it and
then export and you'll be set to use it
in real quantum computers ok so hello
world I hope you are not disappointing
because the hello world of the quantum
computer it doesn't even speed help the
hello world
charities it's much much more basic than
that because we are really like circuits
imagine if we you had like those kids
when you were a kid of electronics we
you had the the end the or the XOR and
you put cables it's more like that you
know so the first choice example is a
tube each other so he it simply take two
takes two bits and some undo the Sam and
what we do here is first we set the the
qubits this one sets this in one and
this maintain is in zero then for the
first binary digit we
okay I think you more or less can
understand that in in this cubed will
have the first binary result and this
one we have the second this is the TOEFL
again so if it detects one and well it
puts the daiquiri
in one you know then this is another toy
example which is a coot and Chandler
what does it does it takes the one of
the qubit and usually had a bar gate to
pour it in in total soup superposition
and then after we have it supper post we
rotate the other one in order to get
them in the exact same position what we
the results for this is that we should
have the same binary digits for for the
for the two because they we put it in an
entanglement state
okay five minutes okay
I'll quickly show you this is IB IB M Q
experience as you know you have you have
a graphical development environment and
I ran this experiment in in a real
quantum computer so 1 0 okay this is a
this circuit has done the Sam in the
computer simulated computer and this is
the result 1 plus 0 is 0 1 it is
inverted let me see if I can show you
okay okay this is very interesting for
example this is the one of the
experiments we've run and as we can see
we can see here the the right answer are
these two you know that will see all
zeros and all ones but what happens here
we have a 1% of the be the results and
here another 2% which are wrong one
particular problem that the quantum
computers have is that you never get
hundred percent right results this is
due to the the the noise in the current
computers so what you do is you repeat
the experiment and incrementing the
number of tries you get the error down
and down and down in the other thing
occurring is that companies are reusing
the the the error of the devices devices
every year more so in the future maybe
this won't be a real problem for us and
here you have the the Righetti
environment I suddenly I don't have time
to run but I wrote a quantum computer
for 30 minutes to run these experiments
basically what you do in regards to
build with Python code the circuit and
run it here for example okay I run it
the entanglement problem and I get two
zeros that like it should be because it
ran in a brittle machine but if I change
this line I can send my calculation
to the quantum computer and get the
result okay
these never works let's see okay as you
know you should never do live examples
probably there was a problem with the
reservation of my machine but believe me
it can run in a quantum computer in Riga
nice setup
okay what can we do what can be done in
the machine learning rearm with quantum
computers as you can imagine the power
is not so high but there is a whole
field of machine learning quantum
machine learning just in the starting
side so what did we do in MercadoLibre
in order to try new things okay
one of the algorithms available right
now is an equivalent of the nearest
neighbors for quantum and the
experiments we did with we was to have
the the shipping start and destination
and basically of that we have a
classical nearest neighbor algorithm
implemented which works really well and
based like in three features it
calculates how many days it will take
for a package to arrive to your house so
we reduced the problem and like right
now you can just have two dimensions so
it's just a work in progress but we call
we were successful in training or
populating a nearest neighbors
field another implementation we have is
a hybrid quantum neural network from
Xanadu so it has a normal neural network
implemented in tensorflow and the last
parts of the process the decision
process is made by the quantum circuit
what we
we tackle was to decide just from the
title of item if the dimension will be
more or less than 70 centimeters for for
each side and so we trying this quantum
your network and we got a final model
it's not performing really well right
now you know because we had to reduce
the dataset but we were successful in
training and hybrid quantum model which
is pretty cool I think because we are an
e-commerce company and we are just
experimenting with this last slide the
future what's coming for the field more
qubits last noise huge huge adoption
thanks for the cloud offerings like the
Amazon one more practical examples of
supremacy you know then the the news
that Google implemented or demonstrated
the supremacy for one type of problem
but it was a really like a toy problem I
hope we demonstrate supremacy in more
practical problems and probably the
program which is tackled by Microsoft
topological quantum computers they are
more advanced types of quantum computers
which don't have the inherent noise
problem we are having right now it's
much less of a problem so this is more
or less the the landscape for the future
that's all thank you for your attention
and open to questions
they are more like three or four fields
for chemistry I think it will be much
more important for chemistry that for
machine learning because you know
chemistry is quantum so I was told like
for example with this you 53 qubits
machine you can you can simulate an
ammonia atom completely you know and the
periodic table has 114 of twenty
elements and in some sense once you
reach that kind of number you will be
able to simulate really powerful
molecules and nothing to save proteins
and something like that
for machine learning is also important
but we have ship used for sometimes but
for simulated nature which is the way of
chemistry this is like a boom you know I
think chemistry is the key field
how long can't you have a long to my SSH
key doesn't work so well regarding
cryptography or yeah now as you know the
most well known algorithm for solving
factorization is is a short I will you
know their their variation but the
highest number we practically have
factorized with quantum computer is in
the order of 200 so chest there is just
a long way until we can factorize in the
order of trillions and something like
that this is not like occurring tomorrow
you know we are factorizing 200 it's
really little what the current machines
can do in that real but they're
increasing exponentially the power so
who knows anybody else anybody else so
the Python examples that we saw we're
setting up the qubits and circuit right
and that's kind of very low level or is
there work on building higher level
abstractions so you could do more
complicated programs yeah for example
the the IBM's kiss kit has for example
an aqua which is a framework in which
you have for the machine learning
algorithms already implemented
I didn't implement the the test
I used aqua which has qn n xn reduce a
quant on your network implementation
children may show because it's the work
of many many PhDs and something like
that for right now I think the way is to
get libraries as you we do in Python and
T I had to just tinker around with my
data set and try to fit into the current
examples as we always do because it's a
really you know difficult things
to get into the algorithms right now No
one more round of applause for Rodolfo
thank you thank you very much for
presenting today